c'est d'abord une réaction de bonheur
imaginez bien que tu en partie en
campagne début juillet en tant
qu'outsider tout le monde sur les partis
classiques pensait qu'ils étaient élus
et que je ne serai pas réélu j'ai donc
entré je suis dans cette campagne avec
beaucoup de lucidité
un ex sincérité et authenticité
proximité aussi et puis avec un peu de
courage pour assumer pleinement mon
soutien à la majorité veut dire comme
tel ce n'était pas facile
donc je crois que cette campagne que
j'ai mené de bout en bout pendant 70
jours et que de 13 mille kilomètres avec
600 heures d'entretien c'est une
campagne de proximité mais aussi bout de
persuasion de plus que j'ai fait en
expliquant et je crois que le capital
sympathie dont je dispose dans ce
département a aussi joué et je remercie
tout se soit bien entendu qui m'ont fait
confiance